we should be thinking about the what AI
is is doing to our society and the
implications of what we're looking for
and so the only I think part of this
thinking has to involve people like
yourself who are more intimate with the
machine learning and artificial
intelligence world is your how do you
reconcile in your mind you said earlier
that you think you can't imagine a
Galaxy where life and intelligence is
not all over the place
and if artificial intelligence is a
natural progression for civilizations
how do you reconcile that with
with the absence of any information
around us or any clues or hints of
artificial Behavior artificially
engineered stars or colonization
computer substrate transformed planets
anything like that it's it's uh
extremely difficult for me it's the the
Fermi Paradox broadly defined as
extremely difficult for me and the the
terrifying thing is one thing I suspect
is that we keep destroying ourselves the
probability of self-destruction with
with advanced technology is just
extremely high that's why we're not
seeing it
but then again my intuition about about
why we haven't blown ourselves up with
nuclear weapons
it it's very surprising to me from a
scientific perspective
but yeah it doesn't given all the
cruelty I've seen in the world
um given the the the power that nuclear
weapons place in the hands of very small
number of individuals
it's very surprising to destroy
ourselves and it seems to be a very low
probability situation with Happening
Here
um
but and then the other explanation is
the is the zoo is the observation that
we're just being observed
that's that's the only other thing it's
just it's so difficult for me
of course all of science everything is
very humbling it would be very humbling
for me to learn
that we're alone in the universe
it would change
uh you know what it maybe I do want that
to be true because you want us to be
special that's why I'm resisting that
thought maybe there's no way we're that
special there's no way we're that
special that's that's where my
resistance comes from I would just say
you know
the specialness is something we we in
implicitly in that statement this kind
of an assumption that we are something
positive like we're a gift to this
planet or something and that makes it
special but you know it may be that
intelligence is more often is like we
like rats or cockroaches we're an
infestation of this planet and we're not
we're not some benevolent property that
the planet would apply would ideally
like to if they have if you can even say
such a thing but we we may be not only a
generally a negative Force for a plant's
biosphere and its own survivability
which I think you can make a strong
argument about but we may also be a very
persistent infestation that may even in
you know interesting thoughts in this in
the wake of a nuclear war
would that be an absolute eradication of
every human being which would be a
fairly extreme event or would the kind
of like Consciousness as you might call
it the flame of Consciousness continue
with some small Pockets that would maybe
in 10 000 years 100 000 years we'd see
civilization re-emerge and play out the
same thing over again yeah that's
certainly but nuclear weapons aren't
powerful enough yet but yes the uh but
to sort of push back on the infestation
sure but the word special doesn't have
to be positive
I just mean
I think it tends to imply but yeah take
your point yeah but maybe
um
just maybe extremely rare maybe yeah
yeah and that to me it just it's very
strange
for me to be
cosmically unique
it's just very strange I I
mean that word the only thing
of this level of complexity in the
Galaxy just seems very strange to me I
would just yeah I I said I do think it
depends on this classification I think
there is sort of again it's kind of
buried within there as a subtext but
there was a a classification that we're
doing here that what we are is a
distinct category of of life let's say
in this case we're talking about
intelligence we have something that can
be separated
um but of course we see intelligence
across the Animal Kingdom in you know
Dolphins humpback whales
um octopuses crows Ravens and so it's
quite possible that
um
that these are all manifestations of
this same thing and we are not uh we are
not a particularly distinct class except
for the fact we make technology that's
really any difference to our
intelligence and we we classify that
separately but from a biological
perspective to some degree it's really
just all part of a Continuum and so
that's why I
when we talk about unique you're you're
you are putting yourself in a box which
is distinct and saying this is the only
example of things that fall into this
box but that but the walls of that box
May themselves be a construct of our own
arrogance that we are something distinct
and uh but I was also speaking broadly
for us meaning all life on Earth
that but then it's possible that there's
all kinds of
living
ecosystems in on other planets and other
moons that just don't have interest in
technological development and maybe
maybe technological development is the
the
parasitic thing it destroys the organism
broadly and then
maybe that's actually one of the
fundamental realities whatever broad way
to categorize technological development
that's that's just a parasitic thing
that just destroys itself